Taking de facto control with a 2.2-billion-dollar bet...
...that bails out its smaller scandal-hit rival,...
...Nissan Motor Company has agreed to buy a 34% stake in Mitsubishi Motors Corporation.
The deal is a lifeline for Mitsubishi Motors.
The company is mired in its third scandal in two decades.
After confessing to manipulating fuel economy data,...
...it has had 3 billion dollars wiped off its market value.
The deal should also be a boost for Nissan.
Japan's second largest car maker has struggled to make inroads into Southeast Asia.
Mitsubishi's models are popular in countries like Thailand and the Philippines.
Mitsubishi and Nissan already cooperate on development and manufacturing,...
...with the partnership dating back to 2011.
That deal, however, does not currently involve any cross-shareholding.